and over the whole world goes a camera  hysterical joy World War one promised us  a perpetual peace and it failed World  War two then was the ultimate laboratory  of death it told us in 1945 what we  should have known in 1939 it took 65  million deaths to prove what should have  been self-evident  the stakes are the stakes of human  freedom which depends upon a view of  human nature and the government that's  appropriate  how we are to live why we are to think  we should live that way and that battle  still goes on anything thank when we say  World War two that cannot be an  abstraction that has to translate into a  guy in a bf109  or somebody in American submarine in  Tokyo Bay the point being is that this  war was unique in that there were so  many theaters there were so many ways of  fighting it that it's almost  incomprehensible let's begin  [Music]  [Music]  you